[Music]
okay rich Cordray I want to do this
interview in good faith but I just need
to get something out of my system before
we began you're a filthy regulator
you're an enemy of the American
businessman filthy filthy awful
disgusting I'm not sure what to make of
that
that guy I'm talking to that's rich
Cordray he ran the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau an unnecessary
bureaucratic agency too Obama created in
2010 why well he thought that the free
market and the banks needed regulation
just because they cause a recession
screwed over millions of people
unbelievable unimaginable on totally
gross but then Trump took over put a guy
in charge named Mick Mulvaney and
stripped the cfpb of a lot of its power
sweet so sweet miss sweets come on guys
this sweetest nectar so now I'm going to
eviscerate rich Cordray because I have a
lot of unaddressed insecurities and open
wounds inside of me to make me take
things out on other people
let's do this hasn't the free market
proven that it can regulate itself well
I think the financial crisis decisively
refuted that notion but aside from that
haven't they shown that they can
regulate themselves they blew up the
economy
there were means that people lost their
homes and millions of people lost their
jobs and we all lost trillions of
dollars in retirement savings that's not
a very good economy at that point
debatable I don't think that's debatable
doubtful you know questionable and I
think there was questionable practices
we also took actions against companies
that had violated the law and we put
back twelve billion dollars in the
pockets of 30 million Americans there
were hundreds of actions that added up
total some of the biggest ones were
against credit card companies that had
sold people products by misleading them
okay that was confusing let's unravel
where did that 12 billion come from
under Cordray the CFPB helps save people
from predatory debt collectors exposed
fraudulent practices at student loan
companies and reigned in manipulative
payday lenders but the worst part is he
forced the sweethearts at Bank of
America and Citibank to pay back over
700 million dollars each because of
innocent mistakes like misleading
consumers and so-called deceptive credit
card practices you're an advocate for
protection
I think people deserve to have somebody
standing up for them and making sure
that they're protected that everyone
knows it feels better without it I'm not
sure which one oh don't make me say it
don't make me sit please don't make me
say I want to say that was sexy I can't
help myself but you know what's not sexy
Cordray actually created a system where
consumers could rapport problems they
had with banks what a gross waste of
time nobody complains about banks we had
over a million 300,000 complaints during
my time there were some of the
complaints hey you're being unfair to
bankers
I don't remember complaints of that kind
No so I remember a field hearing where
this elderly woman stood up and said
that she had a problem and the problem
was that the credit reporting companies
thought that she was dead and there was
nothing she can do to get him to change
their mind and fix her files and that
was an example to me of how people felt
they weren't being treated with dignity
and respect
so did you kill her no we tried to get
her credit file fixed so that she could
be getting loans like any other person
seems like Cordray had a message for
Wall Street stop misleading consumers
but when Trump took over he had his own
message for Cordray there were calls for
me to be fired every day Republicans in
Congress we were trying to get me held
in contempt of Congress and were having
me investigated so how did Trump fire
you he
fire me that's too bad was it tough to
get fired I'm sorry what did you say
well there were a lot of people calling
you and fire me but I let them know that
I would file a lawsuit if they did and
they'd have a fight on their hands and
they never wanted to do that so you
weren't fired
correct you stepped down I did hmm that
makes me enjoy that little less and who
took over for Cordray Mick Mulvaney
finally a straight shooter that openly
admits he only talks the lobbyists that
put money in his wallet during a recent
meeting with bankers Mulvaney said if
you're a lobbyist who never gave us
money I didn't talk to you if you're a
lobbyist who gave us money I might talk
to you simple straightforward awesome I
think it's disgusting which to me
shows a real deep misunderstanding of
what governments about in terms of
serving the people you're a private
citizen you can't do anything about it
anymore well I have a voice I can
criticize things that I think that are
wrong and I'm running for governor of
Ohio to be able to stand up for Ohioans
for fairness the same way I did as the
head of the consumer Bureau so it's kind
of like you're moving back home which is
sad
sorry okay hold on I gotta take this
call hello I know how much yeah in that
case let me find a credit card that
isn't maxed out here no I said yeah I'll
call you right back
this isn't this is a number that's okay
you uh you were saying so good luck Ohio
if you want to protect your consumers I
guess rich Cordray is your guy I mean
that's not my style but hey man where am
I am I in Cleveland oh my god I've been
walking for like five hours
hey Jordan hey it's 1010 bolts from the
show